دائره الفقر ومستنقع الحروب الذين حاصر
التنين الصيني لسنوات اخرجه اكثر شراسه
ووضعه بمصاف الاقتصادات الاولى عالميا
والسبيل لذلك وفق دراساتنا سياسه التعلم
من الاخطاء في الصين تملصت من براثن مجاعه
لتتحول خلال ثلاثه عقود فقط الى الثاني
اكبر اقتصاد في العالم بعد معالجتها
لثلاثه اخطاء
اولها الوثبه العظيمه التي كان يرجى منها
تحويل البلاد من الزراعه الى التصنيعه
لكنها تسببت بمجاعه راحه ضحيتها الملايين
في خمسينيات القرن الماضي اما الخطا
الثاني الذي ارتكبه الزعيم الصيني موتسينج
فكان الثوره الثقافيه بهدف التخلص من
معارضه في الحزب الشيوعيه ثوره اوصلت
الولاده لحافه الانهيار وتسببت بتراجع
الدخل الفرديه الى اقل من 200 دولار سنويا
فيما ثالث الاخطاء يتمثل بالحروب ثلاث
مواجهات مسلحه محدوده زمنيا ومكانيا بين
عام 62 و 79 استنزفت قدرات البلاد
الاقتصاديه وانهكتها هذه الاخطاء علمت
القاده الجدد عدم تطوير الاقتصاد عبر
الصدمات بل اتمامه تدريجيا ليعتده الشعب
ثم تطبيق سياسه الانفتاح على الاستثمار
الاجنبي والقطاع الخاص وتبني نظام
الاقتصاديه الراسمالي في مفارقه غريبه
لبلد شيوعيه وبعد ان كان نصيبها من الناتج
الاجمالي العالمي لا يتجاوز واحدا فاصل
ثمانيه في المئه عام
حققت قفزه النوعيه مع ارتفاع هذا الرقم
الى 16% عام 2020 اي ان اقتصادها تضاعف
نحو تسع مرات خلال اقل من سبعه عقود كما
اصبح القطاع الخاص يساهم بنحو 60 في المئه
من الاقتصاد الصيني
ورغم ان التجربه الصينيه غير قابله
للاسقاط بحذفيرها على اقتصادات المنهكه
لبعض الدول العربيه بسبب اختلاف بعدد
السكان والمساحه والموارد الطبيعيه لكنها
اكثر قابليه للتطبيق في بعض الدول خاصه
تلك التي تجمع بين الموارد الطبيعيه
والبشريه والاستقرار السياسيه وتستطيع
البدء في السير في طريق التنميه